anybody here still ripping butts
hey all right all right a couple you
guys are rare now when I was good
everybody smoked my mom my grandmother
now smogon's like kind of shameful and
then weed used to be a drug used to put
you in jail now weed got its medical
degree and turned his life around
those two completely traded places you
want to smoke a cigarette now you got to
go out in an alley behind a dumpster if
you're like what are you doing over
there you're like uh uh paying a hooker
I'm not smoking I'll tell you that right
now then on the flip side you could pop
an edible at noon like hey I have
anxiety whoa
those two flip flip if my mom would have
caught me smoking weed when I was
younger she would have sent me to
boarding school now your mom finds your
weed she's like sativa what a [__]
weeds everywhere now it's borderline
healthy how do you punish a kid for
smoking weed these days I got caught
smoking cigarettes my dad made me smoked
the whole pack it was hell when he was a
kid with weed now hey Timmy we found a
roach in your room you got to smoke this
whole eighth you'd be like well put on
The Office